pollution des pollutions et pas question
de déposer ici pour évoluer ailleurs
d'une part et puis deux ou trois par ce
que nous disons il n'y a aucun problème
pour la dépollution
cependant sur le fait que la cacem bar
et le le
l'entrée du parc oui ça c'est
inadmissible on ne peut pas empêcher aux
gens de circuler sur le littoral nous
avons déjà menées de combat sur ça et la
loi dit que quel que soit le
propriétaire sur le littoral il doit
laisser le passage et le bassin clip
or là nous avons des chiens qui nous
reçoit des fois et avec dvg d'occident
et puis deuxième chose c'est que nous
disons que avant entre d'entreprendre
tout projet là il faut d'abord résoudre
le problème des riverains qui ont dû
acheter des innovact et le sol mais la
préfecture leur avait demandé d'acheter
des installations ils ont acheté des
installations la demande du préfet pour
obtenir un aute le préfet n'a pas
renouvelé à la hauteur mais n'a pas ce
code et il reste propriétaire des et des
aménagements qui sont achetés
d'abord régler ce problème c'est une pop
c'est un problème de justice
c'est pour cela que nous sommes à côté
que ce livret qui a des doigts à qui on
veut et refuser ses doigts là c'est pas
possible